je pense que pour que les rapports
s'améliorent entre la population et sa
police
il faudrait déjà redonner du sens au
métier je pense que un policier qui est
heureux et convaincu de ce qui fait le
retranscris sur sur le terrain il
faudrait donc abrogé de manière
définitive parce que effectivement sur
le papier ça a été assez c mais en fait
c'est toujours d'actualité faudrait donc
abrogé de manière définitive cette
politique du chiffre
abolir ces primes clivante qui donne
envie aux policiers de de ramener comme
on dit du bâton parce que on parle de
blaze de bâton chez nous pour avoir ces
500 ou 600 euros sur la paie du mois de
décembre en fin d'année parce que c'est
ça aussi la réalité c'est que la police
et comme je vous disais tout à l'heure
c'est aussi un gilet jaune et on est à
500 euros près quoi donc quand on vous
tend 500 euros devant le nez en vous
disant si tu ramènes tant de personnes
on va te le donner et bien forcément ça
ne peut que dégrader des rapports entre
la population et sa police
ça ne peut que dégrader dès lors qu'on a
plus que qu'on laisse plus place à
l'initiative
forcément ça dénature le métier ça que
ça crée de une sorte d'erreur une sorte
d'agora ensuite ensuite sous toujours
sous l'air de monsieur sarkozy il ya une
énorme déflation du corps d'encadrement
les applications auxquelles
appartiennent donc les gardiens de la
paix et c'est cette déflation a aussi
engendré le fait que ce qu'on souvient
tout à l'heure qui est qu une voiture de
patrouille sur un département la nuit
que on attend de 2 heures et demie pour
une prise de plainte etc
il faudrait renforcer les effectifs de
police de manière à pouvoir accueillir
plus de manière plus convenable le
public à ce qui est moins d'attentes
dans les airs et dans les locaux de
police à ce que quand on appelle pour un
tapage on n'attende pas trois heures on
doive par passé quatre ou cinq fois
l'appel tout ça ça ça génère forcément
de de tension de la rancoeur et de
l'attention de la part la population
vis-à-vis de sa police évidemment du
renoncement même parfois des fois de la
résignation
[Musique]